why would I run for it I'm running for
it why would I do this I don't know
don't open hello everybody my name is
Markiplier and welcome back to security
breach ruin we uh ran out of time in the
last episode and there was nothing else
to be done no other reason besides that
I'm a busy man with busy things and have
to do busy life and so
all right whatever so I can't wear my
mask why not what are you doing in there
you know I didn't actually find you that
scary
you were just annoying you were just an
obstacle on my path to Greatness
I'm back when I was Gregory anyway
well it's a it's a good thing that
Gregory is super duper real and alive
that's really a good thing when I think
about Gregory I think about my very real
friend and very alive friend Gregory who
came back here many years later after it
all fell uh to poop
and uh I think explore okay
all right
all right well that was fun good thing
I'm back I just came for a little bit of
fun and that was more than enough fun
for me so if you could just point me to
the exit
you know what I was saying before those
were puzzles for babies well this is a
place for babies so I think it'll
I think it all fits in I think it's all
good an educational experience to learn
to abandon your friends
really teaches kids young that uh
the only thing you need to do to survive
is be faster than the friend next to you
you can outrun them
you can outrun anything
um
okay so why can't I I can
hello what are you doing back there I
don't like that
oh good
let me get info fun yippee try using
your mask yeah I'm trying that's the
thing about this place is it didn't
really let me
uh-huh
sure
great
I'm sure that the more I use this mask
the better off I am in life well
we need to be home you want me to reboot
you
that sounds familiar
[Music]
okay goodbye
well
hang on I gotta get this collectible
I'll be right with you once all the
generators are active use a fast porch
on the back of his face plate on the
back of his faceplate on the back of his
face I need to take his face off I'm
gonna rip his face clean off and then
I know well that's a problem
I know that's not really you so why
don't you just stuff a sock in it
oh does it he she we
are so insightful of you
all right what am I looking at
I got some symbols
I've got some nothing I've got anomaly
ah okay I see
that makes sense wait
I need Moon anomaly first uh oh oh
that's not good
you don't want to hear that one
okay
we're good take it off no thank you
light
light is uh what is that a fly
I almost had it I know that seemed
really slow but I was so fast like
lightning
okay
well I definitely missed being in the
tubes
I know Greg
shockingly Greg you're not helping
oh this
oh that well hold on I I can't uh hold
on I I'm stuck with mask
I don't know how to not mask
uh-huh that's a little weird
oh what a lovely drawing
oh
Monty
I wonder how he's doing
okay ah
fuzzy
all right let's see if I can get just as
lost as I did before in this place
it's scary
maybe a bunny
okay so that is a different pow High
okay so I can go up or I go down I go up
first
of course that's exactly how it gets
super lost never mind it's
didn't want me to go this way I always
find the way that it doesn't want me to
go first because that's just how I do
ah I don't even know what your name is
moon or something
Sun soon
I don't think that's the song
what
huh
huh why'd you stop singing
I don't like that
I was enjoying your fun song
seems rather random
butthole oh
my son all right
so are you going to be coming after me
or something or is this something where
I'm going to be chased
all right I know what this is because
it's like it's trying to be a little
more clear and I know I got lost in but
Greg there's borderline where it's
starting to be insulting okay that's it
it's just a little insulting and that's
it
just respect my intelligence
let's carry on with our lives
oh
well this is a bit more well this is a
bit more open
okay
so where am I going
I want to go back in the tubes
I would like to go back in the tube
's failed to save
I like dudes
okay
yeah I did think that there would be a
lot more um
running and screaming and flailing and
dying
I just had a
a suspicion that that would occur
slightly more than it has
so there was another thing over there
the fireworks over there I don't even
know if that's a thing anymore
screw you okay we need Robo
anomaly no that's a sun
Miss yes you
I know I know
got it
the babies balls are for babies
so did that actually open that up or
says again I don't really know how the
the Realms are bleeding together here
but they certainly are all right hello
I know I'm I didn't do the one that was
right in front of me I understand that
that's probably what I should have been
done but I I I can't
you understand
you understand everybody I can
I couldn't possibly
here
that end over there
all right I'll go
so who are you
and are you the thing that possessed
Fanny
that's just my big brain Theory but
that's probably what it is
I know that there's probably only one
way to go but that seems lame
to only do that oh that's nice
oh wow that's great this is good stuff
uh
funny it looks just like the other one
what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean the
Moon
what do you mean because isn't that
obvious isn't that exactly what it
should be
at least you're keeping over there
that's that's nice
okay well
hi
uh-huh
[Music]
okay buddy yeah thanks pal yeah okay I
got it
actually that is a good reminder
uh but there was
nothing there there was like another
thing that I seem to have entirely
forgotten about
but oh well oh why are you huge
why are you huge why are you huge you
got a secret you shy you wouldn't tell
me something huh
no
no God no no wonder they had to close
everything off how did I ever find this
before this is convoluted this is a
nightmare
all right but I'm on the way
the answer is I never found anything
before
all right one two Skip to My Lou hey
buddy how you do all right I'm gonna do
this
[Music]
thanks he's doing a little late
I need to clean up before we can open in
the morning
with kids
back soon and have a fast horrific day
okay well
uh
you're welcome you're still a little bit
confused as to why that occurred and why
nothing bad happened you know what I
mean
I feel like
there should have been a lot more
Terrible Things occurring
right
it seems to me
like that was the
order of business
okay hi
something's going on here my gamer
senses are tingling something's not
right
and I don't like it
something's up
something's going on that was too easy
look I'm really skilled and incredibly
smart
but that was too easy
what's going on
here ah I see
interesting
oh
I don't like this
where is happening
and even go in there oh man shut up
something's up there's a lot of virtual
baby crying coming from inside that area
over there
there's a lot of stuff going on and ah
I don't know what it is
and I definitely don't know why it is
but something's not right
what was that
all right
what
foreign
hey there's another one of those signals
if it's anything like Montego oh
whatever's locking the theater wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait where am I where am
I where am I where am I where am I where
am I
where am I oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait what how what wait
wait wait
how did I get how how all right I'm
gonna take my mask on and you're gonna
walk backwards
okay
all right
I I don't know how I got backed into the
one corner that I definitely couldn't
walk out from
oh stop it stop now
stop that
okay so there's two views
there's two of uses
two views one you go in oh you go up
okay
all right whatever
I don't like this
okay where is you go
oh where did you go
oh why why
I don't know if that guy's still coming
over this way
but he might be
oh he is oh yeah oh yeah hey bud how you
doing go away
go away I gotta go this way
man you you
you're awful oh I see
all right
it's fine
okay I did it
it's another one of you gonna come out
of hiding
I only hear the one
no no no no no
whatever see I don't know how to get
into wait stop
are you the same one
you the same one
you're the same one
oh
that was quick
you're speedy
I don't I don't like that
oh it opens
it's fine
stop okay what is that
what is this oh yeah this is good
this is what we want
what oh
oh okay
all right that's fine
stop
oh hi
um I know I haven't deactivated all of
you but I intended to
uh
[Music]
twist the right way look I I get that
you're in cool
that you're trying to encourage me
Gregory whoa
but I miss oh you right okay
all right
so that was all of them so I just gotta
get out of here
alive
and then
of course oh
go away what the wait why is this door
that doesn't make any sense okay yes I'm
running for it no I'm not why would I do
that why would I run for it I'm running
for it why would I do this I don't know
just don't open
open was the wrong word and those don't
like it when you stare what else am I
supposed to do that's kind of the only
way to beat him is staring at him
oh no
oh
yeah
I thought these days were over that
makes sense I'm getting punished because
I just didn't do good enough
and that's what I deserve
I am fine what
wait
wait what wait a minute wait no no no
but was that always there
was this always here
whatever I'll do this then
this game's for babies
all right I'm going this way you can't
stop me
oh wow comedy mask
this didn't I get something extremely
similar to that
ah no fun fun and then laugh great good
uh
well so far nothing's online which makes
my life much easier and less
no no
no unless
that one is way too close I do not
remember that one being that close
before
all right whatever
so oh wait a minute
don't do it Dawn I almost forgot the
whole thing
go away
go oh
don't
good no don't no don't
good
whoa I was not there
oh
okay
you just don't get me
for babies
I bet the doors are open now which doors
what do you mean
oh
[Music]
what
huh
what do you mean
oh down there okay well you know it was
so obvious that I I couldn't possibly
have actually done anything about it
oh all right thanks Greg thanks for also
talking in both of my ears one at a time
that really helps me understand your
message so good
all right oh Gregory
Greg
Gregory
all right so I need sun moon and then
you where were you before
Sun well that's probably bad
don't
what could you do to me anyway what
could you do where were you
back here weren't you
sorry you guys to go
I just put on a mission a long time ago
I gotta deactivate all the babies so I
intend to do just that all right let's
try this again don't bother me
son nailed it I'm the best okay let me
keep working please
okay moon no not you Moon got it I'm the
best all right yeah uh-huh
nailed it
all right
well what in the frick
what
in what what
what what what what
where where
I feel like I would have noticed that
before
[Applause]
aha
wow
it's like 3D
I think that's pretty cool I just don't
quite know how it occurred
all right
great
what now
see I don't even know why I did this in
the first oh I know what now don't try
to stop me I know exactly what now
I need to go in your mouth strange thing
to say you know a game like this but I
do
hello don't mind me yep
what how
it's all in your head dude oh yeah of
course
uh-huh well this isn't any better
oh
yeah that's not better
oh good
ah
I bet that's the good kind of mold the
one that's healthy for you it doesn't
have a hundred percent fatality
is really hoping
foreign
you know oh what I was about to say if I
had been able to experience that myself
I would have told you the same thing I
would have said it but even with better
delivery and
would have been more ironic
how did I get here
are these things even remotely close to
each other
I guess maybe it's above I one-man jug
man wow look it's a teen Monty or
something like that
all right
well this is great
um
all right oh wow look
oh there's Bonnie wait a minute wait
what the wait Bonnie wait
wait wait a minute wait what oh Bonnie
Bonnie where's your head Bonnie Bonnie
Bonnie Bonnie
[Applause]
huh
I don't know about this one guys I think
it's
It Ain't So Much a tale as old as time
I'm pretty sure that this is uh
hmm
[Applause]
it's probably leading up to something ah
there it is oh yeah wow yeah you have no
head
you you ain't got no head uh not 100
sure how that happened but okay
foreign
security breach about like there was
like a through Thread about Bonnie oh
how
are you talking to
oh I did it
you're welcome guys I'm just that good
at games
it was quite the challenge but I beat it
now I'm the best I'm the best there is
but there was some kind of a subplot
about Bonnie I always suspected that
something was missed but I guess there
was just wasn't anything about it
whatever I made it to catwalks you said
I could get to the Raceway from here
hold on
the lowest to the maintenance room
deactivate the security node then use
the track controller Gregory you there
I mean it's not if you didn't hear
anything
Curie node and tracking controller yeah
something like that whatever I why can't
you let me do anything Cassie let me say
things I'm here too
I'm in your head oh good hi four oh
all right fine
oh I wish this thing worked oh it
doesn't Okay well
yeah I wish it did too wait
a minute
oh oh yeah
wow I don't know how that occurs
kind of uh if this is all in my
something was happening
maybe I shouldn't be standing on this
thing I keep looking around like where's
that noise coming from oh yes under my
feet oh I'm dead oh
is it
how do you know
is that toxic chemicals
is that
is that whoa you're right it's slippery
okay is that uh is that
is that radioactive chemicals in a
children's Pizza Plex
is that what I'm supposed to understand
ah yeah that of I don't know how but I
don't know what that I don't know any of
this doesn't make any sense at all I
don't get it where's it going on
how is this happening
oh I haven't played a game where there's
been like ice on the floor or any kind
of a slippery floor in so long it's a
weird flashback
oh
[Applause]
up when I need your help I will ask for
it
this is crazy
literally I I have lost my mind
there there is no
reality oh
reality is a vast illusion of
nothingness
well I got one
good
it
the vanity network is someone seems to
be jamming the signal no can
oh oh just in that one second oh God
okay here I go well
I remember why I haven't played anything
with an ice level or slippery floor in a
long time because we agreed all of us
agreed that it was a terrible idea oh
thankfully it did this okay
yeah well
uh all right am I doing this wrong is
there ah ah okay yep that
makes sense that makes sense all right
you know it doesn't make sense any of
this
any of this huh
I'm not gonna go that way I'm not gonna
go that way because I'm not a fool I
think it's all the radioactive barrels
that are clouding my judgment
but I'm fine
you know if you start uh
blasting uh yourself with radiation from
a very early age you'll become
accustomed to it and then you get super
powers
oh
just like Monty everyone look at Monty
as an example
don't worry Monty you're definitely as
good as Bonnie
hmm
huh all right
huh
door
get a puke
how did I get over here I I don't know
why not take a break
I don't know about this one guy hey
stop
it so teleportation is possible not only
possible but probable if you're in the
Fazbear universe
yeah
hmm
what am I seeing there I mean I know
there's something there but it looked
like something else
I don't know what it was there's
apparently a whole lot of nothing hey
oh it's him Monty almost forgot his name
just very forgettable compared to Bonnie
just not as good a name we can all agree
oh well not their fault
their parents just named him that
unless they just like pick that name for
themselves that would be really
embarrassing though
ah it's a corrupted plushie
all right well I've gotten two so I'm
sure that I haven't missed any
definitely not
see I don't understand how these
catwalks fall into this amount of
disrepair
I don't even know like what is the
barrels you're collecting from whatever
the swamp is down there are there
barrels that you shipped in is that a
giant Barrel what is that
was this already here did you bring it
here
thank you
how much radiation do these animatronics
need to function that's what I want to
know
that's what I want to know okay there's
two over here so I haven't missed any
that's good
Wham I'm the best Wham greatest ever
Wham
oh man I
hate uh never mind I'm the best
okay there's a goodie over there you
guys know how much I care about
collectibles
you know how much right it's not very
much
and I'm gonna get them for you
doing all this for you did you know that
it's for you
uh-huh
what
heard something
so I don't understand why these cameras
are here
they don't seem to have too much of a
point
like I don't know what I'm supposed to
be looking for
is Monty supposed to be like crawling
around or something
this one was obvious
because if he is he's not doing anything
what the heck is that a path
it's not a path no way
it was not it was not a path I didn't
jump though so I didn't know if I I
didn't try
it's probably not a path it's probably
not a path there'd be no point in me
doing that again
no I don't know why I tried that unless
I didn't jump soon enough
oh I bonked my head on something I jump
and put a bar so it definitely is not a
thing what is that what is that what are
you what are you
thing a lot of nothing okay that
definitely doesn't go anywhere
definitely because I could have gotten
over it over there if I really wanted to
but I didn't
so I don't need to worry about that
that's not a thing definitely not a
thing 100 not a thing
well I even put a sign here who's gonna
down
I don't know look I don't understand
anything that's going on but then again
I'm not trying to in fact I'm actively
trying to avoid understanding anything
My Hope Is that I never understand
anything at all
I don't understand this what what kind
of interdimensional butthole am I in
I am
what that's what you get
took care of it the area is safe now
yeah I got you wait a minute
won't bother you anymore
what
yeah
uh-huh yeah ah
I
am 100 sure that everything is fine
okay
oh look at this well that's awfully
convenient but before I do that I'm
gonna get this hey yup I made it
haha nice
so where am I
uh
oh I
oh I don't even understand what I did I
pressed the jump I pressed it I don't
think they intended anyone to go back
because they were like why would someone
go for that first one clearly you just
do the thing right in front of you and
then you get it because it's right over
there and that's where you're supposed
to go anyway but I don't think like that
I think it was shiny and then I go get
shiny because I think that I'm gonna
miss out on the shiny if I don't get it
now that's the whole basis of me having
an HD I can't prioritize
his socks fell
my Ramen socks
got him in Korea what am I looking at
you hi I haven't been able to get a new
prescription of a stars for a good bit
so uh it's not
anyone's fault but my own except it's
not but I'm not gonna go into that Spiel
right now I just rely I just would like
to get that
then I would be able to prioritize it
properly oh good I get to go through
this again
ah good thank you for allowing me to be
here I wanted to see this again I know
it's my fault I died I understand that
just allow me to have this moment so I
can reconcile it in my brain
good thank you very much for that I'm
ready to leave this place and oh look a
shiny right in front whoa It's see it's
really it really makes you want to go
get it first you just you know you look
around for your threat assessment you're
just like but it's fine it's not my
fault anyway here we go that rabbit
thing won't bother me ever again
right
anyway
am I supposed to do anything with you
what is the point of you
there I am there that is I did all of
those but what is that what am I looking
at here I have no idea whatever it's
probably fine anyway in case it wasn't
clear the stars is my ADHD medication I
didn't want to think people think I was
just talking about a random drug that I
was like craving or something like that
that's I'm prescribed that or I'm
supposed to be that's why I'm switching
okay I swear to God this is the only
time I'm going to talk about this
because it's just absurd to me I've been
going to the same doctor for eight years
and for the past five or so they just
don't answer the phone and it's been
this bizarre thing where I call and they
don't answer but I leave a voicemail and
sometimes they get back to me but the
thing is for five years I've called this
doctor and they they've answered the
phone once
I was stunned I was flabbergasted when
they actually picked up because it's the
same receptionist that has been there
since the entire time that I've been
there I swear I've never heard her voice
on the phone so I didn't know who I was
talking to anyway
it's not the point of what's occurring
right now in this game
I have been napping a little bit of
trouble with this doctor and I it's
totally legit ADHD medication you could
look it up it exists called starus
there's a whole ass pill thing catching
up on a lot of things that have occurred
since the last time I played security
breach if you've just only coming back
to see my content in that interim which
surprised I'm here
um
this doesn't make any sense
let's see and make it make sense
oh okay thank you thank you very much
for that
why am I here and where am I
just wondering I can't even see you
so I'm assuming you
oh you charged real slow okay so you
Char one of you've got to charge like
cool
so this is fine
ah interesting oh
fascinating
so this is gonna take some skill down
the road it won't be so much a game for
babies
but right now it's a little bit of a
game for babies
and that's
that's what that is
oh can I get in there am I supposed to
get in there I don't think I'm supposed
to get in that then why did I do this
was that the thing that rerouted it
Gregory start whispering me hints shout
them into the void
I'll hear them in the echoes
or I missed a shiny uh maybe I can go
get it
you know you'd think I would like
Collectibles a lot more but the thing is
I can't care about them long enough to
really have a yearning to get all of
them it's just like I just it just I
can't
give it that much of my energy and
that's the problem is trying to give
enough things my energy because I'm
giving all my energy to this right now
but man I can't care about Collectibles
you kidding me
it doesn't exist it's not original
how am I supposed to get it
how was I supposed to get in the first
place how did I miss it where are you
now it's a challenge now it's called me
stupid I'm not stupid
oh it's the same noise from before you
think I'm dumb you think I didn't fall
for that already I am falling for it
again
that's not worth it that feels largely
unbirth it
I don't even know what those are for I
don't like collectibles
become stupid
I'm not stupid I'm a big smart I'm
hugely smart and I'm absolutely smart
hello
oh and oh well I'll get well it's not
for babies
hell yeah wait a minute
wait
oh wait babies I'm I'm babying I'm a
baby at the moment
for babies it's for babies
babies it's just for babies
for babies
games for babies
huh oh
this guy's Soul transfer thing again I
don't know what you do or why or how
rather I'm gonna go with how I don't
know how you do that
all right where do I go now I don't even
know I go there do I get back on the
Gondola what is that what are you golf
you don't even exist exist I also don't
know
if it is like an ADHD thing just to like
be tolerant of something that is
extremely uh like frustrating and obtuse
and just be like Ah that's just the way
it is because I've legitimately been
dealing with that problem and I've been
dealing with like a few problems if
you've listened to distractible at all
you know that I complain often about
trying to get this medication because it
was new and it was I was just like
there's this weird juxtaposition where
if it's something's new pharmacies won't
order it because no one's ordering it
and then you have this weird problem
where enough people have to have a
terrible experience for a medication to
even be available
what I did
oh wait I did but I did all of that I
literally did that but
what do you mean
I did it
what do you mean oh I can do it
Gregory you're of no help at all
Gregory you almost made me go back and
loop through the whole thing
Gregory you're doing this to me
why anyway I don't know if it's just
like yeah lots of problems like uh
but pretty soon I'll get it fixed
because I'm gonna get everything in
order
it's kind of a compounding thing I'll
get there don't worry about me I'm I'm
gonna get there
eventually oh wait I recognize this
do I no yes maybe wouldn't I know that
you'd think I would know that but again
I don't know if I recognize this I'm
getting like vague deja vu but it's not
enough to actually get me all the way to
being like Oh yeah this is familiar what
is going on here and why and once again
poop
so much
because I would say it's dirt or mud but
it clearly is not there's no dirt in
here
only one other thing it could be great
you're getting closer oh no
how are you doing any of this I'll
explain it all when you get here sure
save me Cassie please
uh-huh that thing what thing what do you
mean thing what thing you talking about
because if it's the bunny thing then
didn't you say that you took care of
that thing and that everything was going
to be fine with that thing it seems like
things aren't fine with that thing see
there's a conundrum I don't know which
way to go is that the way that's going
to be the new area
cool
too bad be lonely Greg
I don't know which way which way am I
supposed to go
I'm gonna go that way oh no
this is my fear this is my greatest fear
this is my this is literally my worst
fear is that I go oh what is that
what is that in the bottom right
why why did you make pizza let me go
back
there was another thing down there
oh oh okay
ah
uh oh goody okay all is better anyway
that'll do it for this one now I got a
foxy plush wow look at that that's great
that long ride was so much fun what
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below I died a lot
in this one but that's fine because I am
anyway I'll see you in the next one
bye-bye
foreign